madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir la
grande soirée de l'année commencent
toutes les familles s'apprêtent à fêter
noël et les enfants attendent l'heure de
l'arrivée des cadeaux petits ou gros ne
va pas tarder c'est la première
information que je peux donner aux tout
petits ce soir mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est peut-être la plus
importante c'est à paris que le coup
d'envoi de cette soirée de noël a été
donné un spectacle gratuit sur le parvis
de notre dame avant les cérémonies
religieuses et la messe de minuit
la vedette de cette soirée john baez
free mobile
m
chaussez les reculer
ce spectacle est notre dame
réjouissances et religion c'est en effet
désormais le double aspect des fêtes de
noël et bien souvent le païen
aujourd'hui l'emportent sur la vraie
signification de ce qui s'est passé il
ya près de 2000 ans dans une grotte à
bethléem double signification que
l'actualité nous impose aujourd'hui les
noëls de fait et puis les autres mais
tous ces corps embaumé d'une petite
déception tout de même pour les français
et pour les enfants tout le monde
attendait la neige balaie pas au rendez
vous nous a fait faux bond que
voulez-vous faire frotte le père noël
cette année devra troquer son moto rouge
est chaud pour un parapluie et des
bottes car une vague de plus arrivent
mais si cela peut vous rassurer les
jours suivants il fera plus froid y
sommes peut-être même un petit peu de
neige sur toute la france à ouvrir la
carte pour demain bien une vague de plus
de vouvoyer arrive en ce moment sur les
côtes du nord-ouest
il pleuvra cette nuit dans tout le
nord-ouest du pays une partie de la
matinée demain matin pour la position de
ces nuages dans le milieu de la matinée
avec donc des pluies et des vents
d'ouest par moment assez fort plus sur
le sud est un site sur la corse et bien
il fera beau temps comme ces jours
derniers il faut le dire avec beaucoup
de soleil en attendant tout de même en
fin de journée l'arrivée de ces nuages
et des risques de pluie avec un retour
sur le nord-ouest du pays en revanche
après le passage de la pluie bien retour
d'un temps instable comme on dit avec
nuages avec aussi des éclaircies des
averses de pluie même peut-être de neige
pendant - il faut dire qu'il y aura une
chute des températures d'environ 8
degrés ce sera donc très sensible pour
après-demain bien ces sept ans qui va
l'emporter sur tout le pays
temps instable des nuages des éclaircies
avec du ciel bleu des averses de pluie
de neige en montagne mais également à
basse altitude et donc des températures
en baisse sensible
idem pour samedi avant sans doute mais
c'est un petit peu loin l'arrivée d'une
nouvelle vague de pluie pour dimanche
voilà patrick noël c'est donc d'abord le
souvenir de la naissance du christ il ya
1980 dans une fête religieuse la plus
importante pour la chrétienté ainsi
cette nuit dans toutes les églises les
fidèles vont se réunir pour prier en
france bien sûr mais un pays célébrera
avec une ferveur toute particulière la
nativité
ce pays c'est la pologne est le premier
des polonais le pape jean paul ii ne s'y
est pas trompé en ce moment même il
s'adresse d'ailleurs aux catholiques
polonais donc à toute la pologne
je croupis jean paul 2 s'adresse à ses
frères et soeurs de pologne dit il
depuis sa chapelle du vatican et c'est
un message qui retransmis par la
télévision polonaise ce qui est un
événement
il lance un appel à la paix intérieure
pour ce pays qui depuis quelques mois a
connu beaucoup de difficultés et dix ans
la pologne qui a le droit
particulièrement à cette paix étant
donné tous les sacrifices qu'elle a poli
je reprenais au monde pendant la
dernière guerre et il demande à ce que
le message de noël le message de
bethléem soit aujourd'hui un message
d'espoir un message d'espérance pour la
construction de la pale prix car les
paroles du christ dit ils ne sont pas
des paroles contre quelque chose mais
sont des paroles pour la construction de
quelque chose de nouveau
geoffrey de hockey ce qui est plus
important c'est le fait que le peuple de
ce soir s'adresse aux polonais ou c'est
le fait que la télévision pour le [ __ ]
transmettre ce message est bien écouter
patrick ochs il ya les deux parce que je
crois que ce soir tels que nous voyons
ces images jean paul ii se souvient
qu'il est carole veille témoin l'homme
de la vistule l'homme de cracovie et que
le contexte dans lequel il adressé
parole en rappelant il a commencé son
discours en rappelant les paroles d'un
grand champ de noël que l'on chante ce
soir dans tous les foyers et en
rappelant le lo poi tech qui est le le
pain azyme que l'on se partage et ceci
est assez important car dans tout dans
tous les foyers polonais on peut
imaginer qu'on est en train de regarder
jean paul ii et que la télévision lui
donne de cette audience montre qu' il y
a une volonté que ce noël souhaite à
noël d'apaisement à noël de de démarrage
de quelque chose de nouveau et une
certaine forme de nouvelle étape pour la
pologne l'unité nationale absolument
c'est en ce moment même le pape jean
paul ii s'adresse donc à ses
compatriotes polonais c'est au monde
entier qu'il a lancé un appel hier la
paix devait déclarer le souverain
pontife doit se réaliser dans la vérité
elle doit se construire sur la justice
elle doit se faire dans la liberté
vérité justice liberté trois mots qui
sonnent bizarrement aujourd'hui dans
certaines régions du monde en iran par
exemple pour les cinquante deux
américains retenus en otage pas de nom
libre à washington le président carter
n'a pas voulu que les sapins de noël de
la maison blanche soit illuminée des
bougies ont simplement été allumés
durant quatre cent dix sept secondes une
seconde par jour de détention pour les
otages en afghanistan cette période de
noël marque un anniversaire l'an passé à
cette même heure alors que chacun ici
préparer le réveillon des avions cargos
soviétique se posait c'était sur
l'aéroport de kaboul
le coût de kaboul à cette époque de
l'année le 23 décembre toute la région
est enneigée c'est le pont aérien le
plus gigantesque mises en place ces
dernières années pendant 48 heures on
décharge hommes et matériel on croit
d'abord qu'il s'agit de renfort pour
lutter contre la guérilla islamique en
fait l'invasion de l'afghanistan par les
troupes soviétiques ap les pierres
commencé l'armée rouge prend très vite
les contrôles des points stratégiques
puis les commandos s'empare de la radio
du ministère de l'intérieur de la maison
du peuple et du centre de
télécommunications parallèlement deux
puissantes colonnes blindées fonce vers
le sud objectif verrouiller les
frontières avec l'iran et le pakistan
le coup de force et pratiquement terminé
dernier acte l'installation au pouvoir
du protégé de moscou babrak karmal
aussitôt la résistance islamique réagi
les troupes soviétiques sont harcelés
une partie de l'armée gouvernementale
passe à la rébellion avec ses armes avec
des moyens dérisoires il défie les
quelques 80 milles soviétique qui
aujourd'hui encore ne parviennent pas à
écraser les résistants oui c'était il ya
un an presque jour pour jour à la mi
journée dans antenne 2010 l'un des
responsables de la résistance afghane a
lancé un appel pathétique au monde
occidental le monde entier ne fait rien
at il déclaré ni sur le plan
diplomatique ni sur le plan humanitaire
le monde entier ne fait que regarder ce
qui se passe
pour monsieur baloutche qui répondraient
une question de paul nahon le risque
pour l'occident est pourtant
considérable aujourd'hui
loubinoux s'y est préparé en afghanistan
un million de morts à millions de
cadavres à millions 500 mille de
réfugiés le monde entier regarde cela et
le monde entier ne fait rien sauf elle
les résistants français qui nous a aidés
jusqu'à maintenant monsieur balouche 2
qui recevait vous vos armes
1 nous avons reçu jusqu'à maintenant des
armes des soldats qui désertaient
l'armée afghane souvenez vous il y a
trois ans on avait 120 mille soldats
dans l'armée
et aujourd'hui il
dix mille soldats afghans alors les
soldats ils sont venus avec leurs armes
ils ont pris le maquis
et il se bat maintenant héroïquement
héroïquement comme la résistance
française en 40
mais elle chez baloutche est ce que les
pays occidentaux vous aide en vous
envoyant des armes
pas de tout pas du tout ils nous aident
même pas sur le plan humanitaire
vous voyez nous avons un million cinq
cent mille réfugiés au pakistan alors
ils nous aident même pas alors jusqu'à
maintenant jusqu'à maintenant l'occident
je me demande est ce qu'il laisse
massacrer le peuple afghan contre
l'envahisseur parce que pour nous pour
nous c'est notre devise est liberté ou
mourir oui sur le terrain en afghanistan
les combats se poursuivent mais il est
bien difficile de savoir exactement ce
qui se passe
selon un journal suédois pourtant les
rapports entre officier soviétique et
officier de l'armée afghane serait si
mauvais que l'un des officiers du corps
expéditionnaires envoyés par moscou
aurait tenté d'assassiner le ministre de
la défense afghan ce dernier il ya
quelques jours avait très durement par
été critiqué le comportement des troupes
russes vis-à-vis de la population
afghane message de noël inattendu celui
qu andrei sakharov a pu faire parvenir
de sa résidence forcée de ligue 1
sakharov par le moment même où le procès
de trois dissidents russes a commencé en
union soviétique dans un message simple
andreï sakharov présente ses voeux et il
énumère rapidement les combats qui
occupe ses pensées en cette fin d'année
celui des réfugiés qui meurent de faim
le conflit d'afghanistan justement et
puis il espère le succès des efforts
menés pour le désarmement est aussi dit
il je pense avec un bonheur tout spécial
aux ouvriers polonais qui ont fait un si
grand pas vers le pluralisme
enfin ce jour de noël un procès vient de
s'achever le procès d'un ex empereur à
bangui jean bedel bokassa a été condamné
à mort le procès a duré cinq jours
la condamnation a été prononcée par
contumace l'ancien empereur
centrafricain est en effet toujours
réfugié en côte d'ivoire c'était le jour
de son sacre jean bedel bokassa allait
devenir empereur de centrafrique le 4
décembre 1977
depuis il s'est passé ce que l'on sait
son procès s'est ouvert le 19 décembre à
bangui il aura duré cinq jours
huit chefs d'accusation ont été retenus
contre lui
assassinat ou et blessures volontaires
recel de cadavre et anthropophagie
détournement de deniers publics
séquestration atteintes à la liberté
individuelle atteinte à la vie des
centrafricains de 74 sa chute le 20
septembre
79 cet après midi la cour criminelle de
la république centrafricaine a condamné
à mort par contumace l'ex empereur jean
bedel bokassa un mandat d'arrêt
international a été lancé contre lui ses
biens meubles et immeubles ont été
confisqués
l'iran l'afghanistan mais aussi
l'amérique du sud et le salvador la
corée et tant d'autres pays à climat de
violence d'insécurité de crise
économique il ne faut pas l'oublier non
plus qui va assombrir le noël de
millions de gens pourtant cette période
prend parfois une signification quasi
miraculeuse dans certains pays à noël
les armes se taisent
c'est le cas par exemple en irlande il
ya une semaine dans ce pays on
s'attendait au pire à une nouvelle
explosion de violence aujourd'hui il est
question de trêve et même de libération
d'un certain nombre de membres de
l'armée républicaine irlandaise
quand on dit irlande du nord belfast on
pense ruelles sordides misère taudis
ghetto catholique et c'est vrai du côté
de force fraude chez les catholiques
mais aussi de schenkel chez les
protestants la pauvreté saute aux yeux
on pense aussi aux manifestations aux
attentats à l'insécurité
c'était très veille et une semaine
lorsque les terroristes de l'ira faisait
la grève de la faim et que la mort de
quelques uns d'entre eux semblait-il
l'une en une foule en colère et l image
de nous de l'irlande
mais il ne faut pas s'y tromper belfast
n'est pas que ruines et désolation
terroriste poseurs de bombes et pas trop
tard mais la majorité de la grande ville
du nord ignore les malheurs de la
minorité
et ces jours ci le principal souci c'est
de faire les achats de noël
enfin à condition d'avoir assez d'argent
pour acheter des jouets même au rabais
en raison de la crise économique
en vérité les affaires ne marchent pas
très bien chaud sans précédent il y a eu
des soldes d'un peu tout avant noël car
grève de la faim ou pas ce qui
préoccupait les gens c'était avant tout
le show main un chômage qui touche
surtout les catholiques minorité de tout
temps victime de discrimination quand il
ya une place on la donne de préférence
aux protestants déplace on en offre pas
souvent c'est plutôt le contraire on
licencie un peu partout dans le textile
la chimie 1,6 à carrickfergus petite
ville protestante à quelques kilomètres
de belfast
l'énorme complexe chimique courteau a
fermé ses portes et licencier son
personnel protestant en majorité
l'égalité un peu catholiques et
protestants est ainsi rétablie dans une
commune infortune les chantiers navals
de belfast
les plus grands du monde par les temps
du travail au ralenti et licencié par ci
par là quelques dizaines d'ouvriers de
plus voilà la cause réelle de l'angoissé
qui étreint l'irlande du nord où le taux
de chômage 16% et le double du reste du
royaume uni
noël à belfast aura-t-il vraiment
lugubre non car la tradition de fin
d'année joyeuse reste la plus forte
qu'il n'y a plus de prisonniers qui font
la grève de la faim et qui risquent de
mourir
on peut peut-être commencer à penser à
une reconstruction économique l'espoir
timidement faiblement luis à l'horizon
de 1980
oh
oui reste dans ce tour du monde un pays
meurtri mais meurtri sans que les hommes
est une part de responsabilité dans le
drame en italie la terre a tremblé il y
a quelques semaines
aujourd'hui les morts ont été portées en
leur dernière demeure et les blessés
finissent de se rétablir dans les
hôpitaux m et pour les sinistrés
ce noël sera celui de la tristesse
beaucoup d'entre eux attendent encore
les secours des secours qui ont bien été
envoyée mais qu'ils sont jamais arrivés
dans le sud du pays
la lettre au père noël en poser cette
nuit par les enfants de bâle vagno
d'avellino et des villages dévastés
d'italie du sud nous ressemblent
sûrement pas à celle de l'année dernière
au père noël s'ils y croient encore
ils demandent une vraie maison de la
chaleur ne pas oublier qu'ici il ya
quelques jours à peine deux bébés sont
morts de froid dans des tentes de toile
pour les parents accrochés à leurs
souvenirs à leur mort quelquefois
ensevelies sous les décombres
pas de chocolat ou de marrons glacés
mais les inévitables spaghetti et puis
il ya la peur planté comme une écharpe
une peur sans cesse ravivée par de
légers tremblements de terre trois
secousses hier dans le nord de l'italie
a facilement ce matin en sicile
pendant ce temps les partis politiques
et demi la démocratie chrétienne et le
pc semble se rapprocher dans le sud de
l'italie via tony peut-être par la
nécessité de faire face ensemble aux
problèmes posés par les réfugiés ce soir
dans les villages du sud
il n'y aura pas de messe de minuit avec
grandeur déluge de fleurs mais des cures
est sans doute un peu las de passer de
baraquements en baraquements fraîche et
l'acceptation la volonté divine
en cette nuit de noël les sinistrés ont
certainement besoin de tout leur poids
pour aspirer oui et denise baer qui est
en ce moment même en italie nous
montrera demain à soir comment les
sinistrés l'italie ont passé cette mine
noël je crois que nous avons fait le
tour en partie seulement de ces noëls de
1981 qui ne seront pas des noëls comme
les autres dès noël sans sapin sans
cadeaux hélas sans espoir aussi pour
certains ailleurs et c'est bien normal
c'est la joie qui va l'emporter un peu
partout les lampions de la fête vont
s'allumer même s'il s'agit d'une fête
modeste plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'entre vous ont d'ailleurs déjà quitté
les grandes villes pour la montagne
rien que pour la région parisienne plus
de 500 mille personnes auraient ainsi
déserté leurs foyers
le président de la république lui et
depuis le milieu de la nuit en
guadeloupe un voyage un tout petit peu
mouvementée à bord du boeing d'air
france pour monsieur giscard d'estaing
et sa famille ainsi que pour 380
passagers une fuite d'huile à un
réacteur a contraint le commandant de
bord à demi tour rapide vers orge trois
heures de travail pour les mécaniciens
et puis ensuite un vol sans histoire
après un accueil aux antilles françaises
sans protocole seuls le préfet et les
élus à l'exception de monsieur aimé
césaire étaient présents le président de
la république a gagné sa résidence de
vacances avant de prendre le volant
le chef de l'état avait toutefois
expliqué qu'il avait choisi d'aller
passer les fêtes de noël au milieu deux
compatriotes antilles pour leur
témoigner l'affectueux solidarité de la
métropole pas de politique aujourd'hui
si cette même une querelle à propos du
budget de la communauté européenne lundi
le conseil des ministres des neufs
avaient renoncé à se prononcer sur le
budget de cette communauté
et hier soir le président de l'assemblée
d'un à strasbourg madame simone veil a
décidé d'arrêter définitivement le
budget supplémentaire de 1980 et le
budget de l'année prochaine de 1980
le gouvernement français vient de faire
connaître sa position il considère que
les décisions prises par madame simone
veil constitue un détournement
grave de procédure le gouvernement
français estime qu'il ne peut admettre
que les dispositions du traité soit
ainsi détournées de leur objet paris
entend donc tirer les conséquences de
cette situation notamment en ce qui
concerne les appels de fonds de que la
commission de bruxelles lancera pour
financer l'an prochain des dépenses de
la communauté européenne
alors voilà pour la politique je propose
de revenir bien vite aux vacanciers à
noël et des vacances pour beaucoup
d'entre vous c'est donc le ski les
quatre grands pays alpins 10 plus
dispose pardon d'un domaine skiable à
peu près comparable petit avantage tout
de même peut-être pour la france elle
bénéficie d'un ensoleillement importante
tout en gardant une neige d'excellente
qualité
résultat selon les spécialistes les
pistes de ski français sont parmi les
plus belles dents alors dans ce bilan
particulièrement favorable il ya tout de
même un petit point noir est ce petit
point noir c'est la cas isna si que
certaines stations françaises ont décidé
de porter leurs efforts vers la
formation d'employé loprais appelle le
pot de secours on est là on procède un
exercice
imaginons que le télécabine soit en
panne d'esker sont bloqués là au cera
rassurez vous de plus une quinzaine
d'années apparition de matériel
sophistiqué nécessitant des spécialistes
qui ne seront employés que pendant la
période hivernale
c'est justement pendant cette période
qu'agriculteur de montagne certains
artisans ne peuvent plus exercer à cause
du froid et de la neige
vous devinez la suite nous avons mis sur
pied d'estale qui contribue à qualifier
les gens dans ce style stages de
formations techniques d'accueil et et
stages de maîtrise de la langue anglaise
est le deuxième niveau et bien c'est
pour permettre à nos ruraux de s'insérer
dans la promotion sociale qui suit le
développement de l'industrie du tourisme
dans nos stations de sports d'hiver
et pour se perdre leur permettre de
s'insérer nous avons mis au point des
stages dont le but est de les former aux
métiers de la neige
mettez la neige l'enseignement du ski
mais aussi la conduite des remontées
mécaniques
bon ben chantant le camp tu veux un tu
peux descendre donc évacuent les 4 gaël
l'école de stival et réceptionnés à la
base la frotte l'association pour
l'information des ruraux aux activités
du tourisme pour but de stopper le
départ vers la ville des agriculteurs et
artisans en les faisant participer à
l'essor touristique de leur région
les mairies sont chargés de susciter des
vocations de plus en plus souvent les
remontées mécaniques sont municipaliser
alors autant employer quelqu'un du pays
tu accompagnes accorde également qu'elle
ne touche pas le bord de la cabine pour
éviter qu'elle se couche voilà c'est
très bien mais on peut laisser descendre
n'y a pas de problèmes propres
installations de giffaumont papier sable
mais il pratique et séjours système de
verrouillage
cette poignée là à l'issue de leur stage
ces jeunes seront des pluriactifs ce mot
ne figure pas encore dans l'ic soner
disons qu'il est synonyme d'adaptation
une région et d'un certain courage mon
principal travail sur l'agriculture pour
le moment et puis comme avait lutté aux
normes est assez faible
alors je prépare des stages de ski pour
faire moniteur autre lieu mais parfois
même stagiaire ici apprentissage des
techniques de cali plan intervient
première erreur qu'a fait l'hôtesse j'ai
pas si vous avez remarqué la présenter
le document le plein de ses stages sans
que ce n'est pas un examen sont
organisées à la demande des
municipalités
lorsqu'il ya suffisamment de candidats
bien sûr l'été je suis bûcheron c'est à
dire un métier que je peux pas faire ici
l'hiver j'ai choisi de faire un métier
de la neige enfin de préparer ce métier
et qu'est ce que ça vous apporte
ça m'apporte l'intérêt que je peux
rester ici l'hiver sans être obligé
d'aller travailler à la ville par
exemple pour nous avons vu dans la
dernière fois comme en une phrase il
parfait professionnel de la neige parle
une langue étrangère on saigne le ski
c'est accueillir un groupe de touristes
réparé un remonte-pente et pratique le
sauvetage en montagne
c'est beaucoup pour une seule personne
attention donc à newman chauffer quelles
sont les caractéristiques de ces
appareils
c'est beaucoup aussi les habitants des
régions de sports d'hiver se sont-ils
partager les tâches plus de cent mille
emplois à caractère touristique qui ont
été créés en dix ans dans les alpes le
ski c'est surtout pour les grands et en
ce soir de noël on ne peut pas oublier
les petits et donc les jouait pas ce que
les enfants vont trouver ce soir au pied
de l'arbre
parmi les oeuvres d'art de nos musées il
ya un certain nombre de jouets anciens
qui sont en effet de véritables
chefs-d'oeuvre exécutés par des artisans
avec une précision et un soin tu fais
merveilleux alors à quoi jouer les
enfants il ya cent ans
ceux dont les parents étaient assez
fortunés pour se payer ses véritables
oeuvres d'art pour le savoir une visite
s'impose celle de l'unique musée du
jouet en france il se trouve faisait
exactement à poissy c'est dans les
yvelines
vous avez ici trois poupées de marque
conserve et d'époque 1881 vous pouvez
remarquer naturellement le luxe de leur
ville et de leur costume
c'est en poupe et son temps
naturellement en porcelaine qu'on
appelle du biscuit de la porcelaine
maths et elle présente la
caractéristique d'avoir une tête à
l'aspect tout à fait enfantin jusqu'en
1860 débuts de l'industrie du jouet les
poupées ressembler à des femmes
celle-ci souvent d'ailleurs en possédait
les poupées en effet était en même temps
des mannequins de mode et des objets de
luxe
déjà cependant en 1850
au japon on fabriquait ce magnifique
bébé portrait du petit garçon auquel il
appartenait et oui un jouet à
l'expression très moderne dépôts actuel
que chérissent tant les petites filles
outre jouet de luxe pour les fillettes
d'il ya cent ans les maisons de poupées
avec tout leur mobilier accessoires la
minutie parfaite des détails devaient
avoir pour l'enfant une vertu éducative
la petite fille à laquelle cette maison
poupée appartenait avait en modèle
réduit et en réduction dans sa maison de
poupée tous les objets mobilier bibelots
et accessoires de sa vie future
évidemment vie parfaitement bourgeoise
est tout à fait conforme à un certain
modèle aisée 1
les garçons ne jouais pas beaucoup à la
coupée ou alors c'était assez rare est
assez original si vous voulez et jouer
beaucoup aux soldats beaucoup surtout
dans cette période de juste après la
guerre 70 c'est avant la guerre 14 avec
des soldats en est un avec des soldats
en plomb avec des soldats en imagerie
d'epinal découper qu'il découpait à la
main s'appelait des soldats cartes qui
étaient vendues quelques sous dans les
épiceries ni recevait du coin et par les
colporteurs
et c'est le début de ce que l'on appelle
les jouets de bazar ou joujou de
quat'sous en fer blanc en bois en taule
naïves très colorées réaliste au
mécanisme simple on en trouve encore
dans les baraques de nos marchés ils
viennent d'extrême orient
mais les anciens eux ont presque tous
disparu
c'est la caractéristique du jouet
moderne il se casse bien vite
inutile de demander c'est jouer au père
noël
il en a plus en stock le ski les jouets
mais il nous reste tout de même les
spectacles et plus précisément le cinéma
le rêve américain celui des migrants
télé le thème du prochain film de milos
forman ragtime un film qui est en
tournage en ce moment dans les studios
de londres vous verrez ragtime dans
quelques mois dans un an même très
précisément ce sera pour la noël de 1981
mais georges bigot est aller respirer
l'ambiance du tournage dans le studio
il faut dire que l'entreprise ne manque
pas d'envergure
des milliers de figurants pour une
amérique du début du siècle un titre
d'époque un titre musical ragtime le
chef d'orchestre de ce film milos forman
un réalisateur tchèque que les états
unis ont adopté est couronné à hollywood
pour vol au-dessus d'un nid de coucou
avant le triomphe de r il y a deux ans
mais réussir en amérique n'est pas une
chose facile il faut être très patient
avec les américains beaucoup de patience
pour que j'ai je prenais plusieurs mes
amis des quarts en selle français une
bouteille sur le nuit et quand elle les
choses se passaient pas dans six mois
bronze et vous avez tenu je n'ai pas de
choix
ragtime est au départ un roman à succès
de dr lô publiant 75 une saga où
s'entrecroisent les destinées de ces
migrants venus de tous les points du
globe et dont les idées et les énergies
pèseront dans le développement de
l'amérique que nous connaissons je
montre beaucoup d' emilie est tellement
différent parce qu'on voit on voit la
preuve par le plus aux sociétés
américaines la vie des héros
aristocratie nouveau américaine en
décembre un jeune bourgeois nos
bourgeois adorent cher la famille dans
la maison là-bas à petiville près de
faire une recherche
après le descendant de
laurie zaïtsev milieu des déliquants des
pauvres d'europe des juifs craignant au
brillant allemand jusqu'au arlene c'est
aux studios shepperton à londres que le
new york de 1906 a été reconstitué tout
le quartier du madison square dressé en
plein champ on se croirait revenu au
plus beau temps d'hollywood
le producteur dino de laurentiis a
engagé 25 millions de dollars dans cette
entreprise
environ 12 milliards de centimes le rêve
américain coûte cher mais l'exaltation
unanimiste des hommes de bonne volonté
n'a pas de prix milos forman n'a pas
fait appel aux grandes vedettes
d'aujourd'hui
il a employé les personnalités qui n'ont
pas d'expérience de comédien c'est le
cas de l'écrivain norman mailer qui joue
un architecte socialiste et bon vivant
qui sera assassiné au cours du spectacle
donné au madison square garden le coup
de revolver qui doit briser la soirée
c'est forman lui même qu'il était fort
mal mais pas un metteur en scène qui
gouverne ses assistants depuis son
fauteuil il veille à tout vérifie le
cadre des caméras donnent aux acteurs
des indications précises
il multiplie les prises et garde à ses
côtés
la chorégraphe toyas tarbes qui a réglé
la séquence des girls autour de donald
o'connor le résultat n'en doutons pas
fera courir les foules
foreman dispose de gros moyens mais il a
le talent de nous raconter des histoires
qui donnent à réfléchir en nous
divertissant
leisinger foulée je mène ma scène rock
mais le sol la brader ce mail sorte ça
fait mal aux animaux de la brousse à
plusieurs
oh
aaron la zone médiane coeur j'essai
vigueur
toni giger irak taille mais ce sera pour
l'an prochain
pendant et 1980 le loto faudra
probablement quelques heureux ce soir
voilà les numéros qu'il fallait jouer le
7 le dise le 15 le 31 le 34 47 avec un
numéro complémentaire indispensable le
numéro 35 équipes il y aura un tiercé de
vincennes dans le prix constantin
hervieux 18 partants 2250 mètres grande
piste
pyrène presse vous propos jackson le 12
indications le 6 jakin à le 16
ycare le 14 yg néo-bleu 11 et puis cela
s'impose aujourd'hui gérant de mam le
sac voilà il est 20h30 parce que 32
minutes
il n'y aura pas d'autres journal ce soir
l'actualité pour vous comme pour nous ce
sera le réveillon à la rotonde de toute
la rédaction d'antenne 2 je vous
souhaite de passer une très bonne soirée
peut-être en notre compagnie sur antenne
2 justement le programme est riche avec
en point d'orgue la veillée à partir de
23 heures avec notamment ce choeur
basque que vous découvrez à tous et
surtout à ceux qui ce soir son seul bon
noël
à